if you are doing a film that you've got
to achieve a retro look for really any
film the production design is Paramount
I'm Chris ilicky I'm the Director of
Photography for third Saturday in
October and third Saturday in October
part 5 which are two slasher films that
are supposedly a lost slasher film
franchise that started in
1979. I wanted to make this video for
you guys to kind of show you a little
behind the scenes of what went into
getting the look that we did
specifically for third Saturday in
October the first one which is set in
1979. this movie is directed by one of
my best friends Jay Burleson he and I
met at sidewalk film festival and if
you're ever looking for reasons to go to
film festivals I would say that's one of
the main ones is that you can meet
incredible like-minded Folks at a film
festival and I mean I met one of my best
friends there
stop it
I think really the answer to how we
achieve the Retro look was that Jay
pulled together a team of people all
focused on different areas of making
that happen and we coordinated well
enough to pull something off that I
think's fairly convincing
if you are doing a film that you've got
to achieve a retro look for really any
film the production design is Paramount
and I find that a lot of times
cinematographers will get credit for
things that really probably the
production designer should be getting
credit for so for all you production
designers out there my hat that I'm not
wearing is off to you my friends
there's all these departments all these
team members putting forth their best
effort to tell your story yeah and
they're putting all that stuff in front
of a lens
and it gets turned into photons
and goes through that glass to the film
plane or to the sensor in the camera
and that's the first
gatekeeper of what your look is is the
glass
Jay knew he wanted to have active zooms
because we were going for a 70s
aesthetic so I knew okay we we need a
par focal zoom and you know if we're
going for our 70s aesthetic let's get a
lens that's
you know a 70s lens I think choosing the
ingenue 15 to 150 millimeter
um was the first step in a series of
decisions that kept us consistent with
the 1979 look it just renders things in
a very pleasing way and it feels
authentic because it kind of is
authentic as a piece of glass for that
period we used
um The switar lenses the little turret
lenses that come with the bollocks we
had a 75 and we had a 25 they're like
little C Mount lenses that we put on
there the 25 we used for an establishing
shot
and I think we might have used it on
Denver's dancing scene and on a car
mount shot with Heather doing little
things like that getting that actual
retro glass in there those little things
sprinkle throughout the film and they
kind of you know have a subconscious
effect and just kind of help sell it to
you a little bit more so this is a
Bronco burger and we're shooting at
night trying to make it look like
daytime
in here we have the partly cloudy look I
call it but what it is is it's a couple
of aperture
300 X's with Toppers the cuts that are
with fresnel kind of spotted in
see it's night time but we're trying to
make it feel like there's a bunch of
light coming in through these windows so
we have a Nova with an egg crate
and I've got another Nova playing
through this diffusion right here
and it's just kind of an ambient fill
to this area where a lot of action is
going to be happening
I think my schooling which was in the
90s around filmmaking was very helpful
when coming up with how to film the
third Saturday movie because I learned
using textbooks from the 70s all the way
I thought as a film student still plays
and the people I learned coming up they
were filmmakers in the 70s and a lot of
the films that I love are from the 70s
so it wasn't a stretch for me to put my
brain there and I think that helps if
you're working on a retro piece to try
to get your mindset adjacent to the
mindset of the filmmakers you're
referencing
one of the references Jay and I had for
third Saturday in October was The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre and particularly the
Moonlight in the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
it's a very blue kind of Moonlight and I
think this speaks to that tungsten
versus Daylight
mindset that I used to have with when
shooting film if you're shooting on
tungsten film night exterior and you put
a full blue gel on a Tungsten light
that's Moonlight it's blue that was the
frame of mind that I went into third
Saturday with now with modern stuff A
lot of times We'll add in a little green
I'll kind of try to do some things
differently to kind of get a silvery
kind of moonlight but you know when they
were doing the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
they went full blue and in some I mean
the the Moonlight in that movie is very
blue so we wanted to do that and that's
kind of what you see with some of the
nighttime exterior stuff and the
lighting is super important you know
there's a lot of things that you can
look at when you start studying the
history of film and you start breaking
down imagery from previous work you've
got less sensitive film stocks you're
shooting at 25t you know you're you're
down at 50 daylight you know you're
you're you need photons you need lots of
photons but you don't have a lot of
money to get really big lights and then
break them up and soften them so you're
just having to point medium lights you
know at your subject without softening
it at all so that's where these harder
you know out of necessity they're just
going to be harder Shadows harder light
sometimes
100 watt light bulb with black wrap can
do so much put a dimmer on it and you
can warm it up you can you know dial it
down
um and turn it on and off real fast
flicker it all that kind of stuff
they're tiny they're lightweight you can
clamp them into corners and hide them in
the ceiling and put them on the end of a
stick and that's the light that I
learned how to light with when I was
doing VHS movies in the 90s everybody
had some 100 watt light bulb scoop lamps
in their garage you know that you could
go grab and just get a bunch of those
and poke them around and point them at
things and light it so you can see it
you know so this is what we got we got
this jib going here
uh
but a little camera
the pocket jib right this is Sean he's
the man yeah he's got the plan we got
some Moonlight happening right there
yeah we had a Moonlight key light we had
a headlight gag that was playing on the
house to bring out color contrast but I
forgot that there was a car right next
to the scene until the actors are ready
to go and realized we needed to add a
light real quickly luckily the gaffer
Chad
already had a good run of electricity to
the front of the house with a cube tap
ready to go so it was very easy to add
that light at the last minute which was
something I had forgotten and it changed
the entire Dynamic of the scene because
it adds a warm key light
that contrasts the Moonlight sometimes
it's like right before you go that you
come up with an idea that's like oh man
this makes sense and it can really make
the scene
come alive
early on you know you're kind of coming
up with all your rules and once you
establish your rules you're like okay
we're shooting we're not going to shoot
on Modern Glass modern glasses out of
the question we're gonna shoot on a
camera with a small sensor that's
nearest to 16 millimeter that we can so
the depth of field matches we're going
to use a zoom lens that has par focal
Focus so that we can do active zooming
as an aesthetic we're going to do full
blue Moonlight and actually make it even
more blue to kind of mimic that Texas
Chainsaw Massacre Moonlight harder light
is okay you know you can get away with
harder light in certain scenes you don't
have to make it all pretty and soft like
a modern movie and you get going and you
start shooting and you're real
meticulous about like okay did we do it
is it there but once you establish it
and you start shooting and a week goes
by you kind of go ah all right this is
it and then
you're just making a movie
we are here on the um location for third
Saturday in October part one
we've got a CAM 8 right here he's got
pan tilt control and such
so lighting we got a lot of dirt because
all our stands are fully deployed up so
that's bouncing off that foam core and
then you can see the lamps
they're all shooting up in the card so
that's a 600D and two 300 D's with for
nails the crane brings the camera out to
here and we watch as the sheriff gets
out of this vehicle he gets out
and if you look behind us up here
there's a sodium vapor light street
light
and it's cast in the shadow of the
uh crane onto the car so what we've done
is we've taken a four by floppy right
here
and you can see that that's taking not
light away
if we're replacing exposure with this
100 watt bulb on a scoop and a dimmer so
that we can control it to taste so it's
not too source so you just fill it
it's just to get some color on there
at the end of the day every team member
is trying to do their best work and make
the vision come alive as best it can be
and that's the culture of film that I
love is just like this raw determination
to make your dream come alive you know
and and that was what we had on the
third Saturday movies both part one and
part five I hope you've gotten something
out of watching the behind the scenes
look at us pulling these movies off and
gotten some ideas for your own projects
and thanks to film courage for letting
us get the word out take care